Bonjour
Pour commencer je citerai Manimal qui disait :
[BRUIT D'AIGLE]
Aujourd'hui je reçois Sebastopol Figuero
Sebastopol, bonjour.
Bonjour
Alors vous êtes l'homme qui peut changer d'apparence à sa guise
A ma guise.
Alors la première question qu'on se pose c'est
"C'est votre apparence de base ou c'est vous qui avez choisi ?"
Bah, je sais pas, vous pensez vraiment que c'est le genre de physique qu'on choisie ?
Alors, comment vous faites?
Un peu comme Arturo Brachetti le transformiste,
vous mettez un drap et hop, vous êtes en robe ?
C'est pas exactement ça.
Ha oui d'accord là on est vraiment sur un autre physique.
Alors comment vous faites ?
Bah en fait, je pense à quelqu'un et je me transforme, directement.
C'est là que ça se passe
Donc là par exemple si vous pensez à , je sais pas, monica bellucci, ou michel goujenat, vous pouvez ?
Je peux .
Ah, c'est dommage on a pas pensé à la même personne..
vous savez que je peux vous faire changer d'apparence aussi, si je veux ?
Ha oui ? vous faites comment ?
Je vous touche, allez-y. Pensez à votre meilleur ami.
Quoi ?! je suis Frank ? je suis mon meilleur ami ! on se connaît depuis qu'on est enfant, c'est fou!
Pensez à votre sœur
Incroyable !
Pensez à la première personne que vous avez vue nue.
Je suis Sophie bouvier, c'est ça ?
nan. Ha oui, tonton Michel...
oui. Pensez à votre première petite amie
On habitait dans un petit village.
Vous êtes devenu sombre.
Bon, je me permet quelque chose d'un petit foufou,
Je suis extrêmement fan de rihanna, est-ce-que vous pouvez penser à elle ?
Je connais pas
Bah! rihanna, la grande médiseuse aux yeux clairs qui chante
"bitch better have my money "
bitch better have ma monnaie ..?
Bon, remettez moi le gros.
Re ! vous savez que je peux changer de lieu aussi ?
Ah bon ? Et comment vous faites ça ?
Il faut se lever pour ça.
Vous voulez aller où ?
je rentrerais bien chez moi.
je vous cache pas que je suis pas super à l'aise.
Oueh, c'est des choses qui arrivent.
ah oueh ? hum hum !
Salut ! Frank ?!
C'est pas du tout ce que tu crois.
Oh putain tu m'as fait peur mon con, je croyais que tu étais en train de baiser ma femme !
Ta femme ? hahaha attends, eh mais je suis qui moi ?
Bah t'es mon frankiki !
bah voilà !
Tu restes à la maison ce soir, on se boit un petit apéro ? oueh
tu sais que j'ai imaginé le pire hein ?
ho tu te fais des histoires dans ta tête toi !
Et tu sais que ce mec là, là-bas, il change d'apparence quand il veut !
waouh sans déconner ?
Je me casse.
Comme disait mon tonton michel, abonne toi, tu verras, ça fait pas mal.
Sinon, il y les vidéos du lab, tous les vendredis à 18 h sur le site.